في محيط مدينه تشافيار في منطقه شرق
اوكرانيا والتي تبعد عن مدينه حوالي 17
كيلومترا تتحرك الدبابات الاوكرانيه
والعربات المدرعه القليله الى مواقعها
فيما يطلق الجنود الاوكرانيون قذائف
المدفعيه على الاهداف الروسيه في مدينه
يقول القاده العسكريون الاوكرانيون انها
تهدف الى كسب مزيد من الوقت قبل شن هجوم
مضاد فيما يتعلق بحماسنا للقتال اقول اننا
نقاتل من اجل النصر نحن بحاجه الى النصر
وليس السلام فحسب
رئيس مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه الخاصه اعلن عن
تقدم جديد لرجاله الذين يقاتلون في بخموت
في حين اعلنت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه قد
سيطرت خلال الايام الاربعه الماضيه على
الجزء الاكبر من شرق المدينه اما
المخابرات البريطانيه فقد اعلنت في تحديث
لها ان خط المواجهه في القتال من اجل
باخموت اطول معركه داميه منذ الغزو الروسي
قد تغير لكن اي تقدم روسي اضافي في
المدينه المدمره قد يمثل تحديا كبيرا حسب
المخابرات البريطانيه بعض الخبراء
العسكريين يشككون في مغزى الاستمرار في
القتال من اجل بخمت لكن المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين يقولون ان سقوط البلده قد
يؤدي الى مزيد من التقدم الروسي في الشرق